when dada first came out your baby's
first words will be dada 2015.
i remember looking at the cover and
going oh wow
that's so smart that is
just too good it's so crisp it's so
clean
it's so clear there's an unwritten
thing i think with the moms and dads
where you want the baby to say mama or
dad at first
nancy obviously doesn't really care but
i do and so i was
doing anything i could do to have winnie
say dada so i was giving her like
a bottle i'm like do you want to do you
want a dad dad like i don't care if
the kid's dumb as long as she says dad
at first i'll let her figure out being
smart later
uh and then she said mama that was her
first word so i go there should be a
book where it's just
data quack dada moo data and you just
keep saying the word dada
and i released it and it was like oh
that was fun but then huge
huge huge record-breaking best-seller
crusher
but the best was the videos and stuff
and and the feedback from people were
going like
the kid loves reading the baby's
laughing and you're reading a book with
your baby and that
and i've had like teachers and and go
like you're building confidence
as a child into reading and you're
making i'm like yes
of course i knew that yeah that was my
goal all the time you know the whole way
but it's like
a different buzz and you get that kind
of buzz that probably teachers get where
they go like
i just taught somebody something that's
it's amazing
okay so five more sleeps until christmas
um
we i love this book so much you have
dada mama and baby 2015
uh 2017 2019 all bestsellers
five more sleep still christmas has
broken records again
broken records knock on wood yeah it's
crazy and this was a very different
world as you see we made our set
look like the book this one is a
different move and it's just more for
the holidays and i loved
you know i couldn't wait for christmas
and i have kids now and
uh they can't wait and it's like how are
you gonna get to sleep before
santa comes and i was walking winnie
home my daughter from from school
and she goes uh how many more how many
more sleeps till we go to grandma's and
i go
how many more sleeps that's so cute do
people say that like i've never heard
we have five more sleeps till i go
that's something that is so cute
so i go we should do five more sleeps
till christmas so i'm
i didn't give winnie writing credit but
i'm currently our lawyers are talking